and our morning rounds at home to raise
awareness of heart disease today is Go
Red For Women day that's why we're all
wearing red well the new report
estimates that nearly half of all adults
in the US have some form of heart or
blood vessel disease the increase is
mostly due to recent guideline changes
that consider high blood pressure at a
reading of 130 over 80 heart disease is
the number one killer of women but only
55 percent of them know that it's their
greatest health threat our doctor Taryn
Arul is a cardiologist at Lenox Hill
Hospital part of northwell health and a
spokesperson for the American Heart
Association welcome such an employee day
for you to be here and a perfect example
of a patient
Danil right of yours yes who on paper
looked healthy and yet there was a
mystery hidden inside her body that that
was a ticking time bomb
right and so you know this month we talk
a lot about the statistics one out of
every three women will die of
cardiovascular disease CVD kills more
women than all forms of cancer combined
but what I believe is going to change
the battle is humanizing this disease
and giving it a face the face of your
mother your sister your best friend your
co-worker in this case my patient daniil
she did not look like what a lot of
people think cardiovascular disease
looks like in a woman she was 58 she had
a little high cholesterol in a family
history that's it she didn't have high
blood pressure she didn't smoke she
wasn't overweight she wasn't diabetic
she walked 10,000 steps a day and she
had a Mediterranean diet she came to me
and she didn't have profound symptoms
she said I ate a steak dinner and I went
running to a Broadway show at a little
indigestion so I sort of blew it off I
thought it was heartburn but then it
happened again when I was running to a
doctor's appointment that feeling of a
little pressure so I'm telling you
doctor Narula
so I said okay we're gonna send you for
a test I got a call that day that she
had a very severe blockage on a cat scan
we sent her for an angiogram and in fact
she had an 80% blockage of what we call
the left main coronary artery if this
remained untreated it typically will be
fatal within several years so she was
stented the blockage was open she's now
doing great she's in cardiac rehab but
really what the idea is that this was a
mother she owned a dance studio she was
a wife in the prime of her life she did
not become a statistic she became a
survivor because she talked about she
mentioned her symptoms and she
prioritized her health so what do you
what are the warning signs I mean cuz
because if it's indigestion might be on
the phone all day long okay this is
what's tricky right so for women there
are several different things that heart
disease can present us so it can
certainly be a feeling of indigestion
chest pressure burning squeezing
tightness it can also be arm pain back
pain jaw pain shortness of breath
overwhelming fatigue nausea vomiting
like headedness so a whole array of
symptoms but important to recognize them
and act on them and since 80 percent of
this is preventable
what are some of the steps that we can
take so step number one is whatever your
to-do list says today take my kids to
soccer go to the office let's move up to
the top of the list know my risk of
cardiovascular disease and goes talk to
my doctor about it your doctor can sit
down with you and identify what your
risk factors are then they can figure
out with you what your numbers are and
you should know them your blood pressure
your cholesterol your body mass index
your blood sugar and then you can take
steps the American Heart Association is
what they call life's simple seven seven
things you can do to really turn around
and reverse your risk why do more women
die of heart attacks than men well other
than the issues with awareness right on
the women's side there's issues on the
science side too so as doctors we
haven't really treated women the same as
men unfortunately many women are told
you're just stressed out you're anxious
they don't get as aggressively treated
when they go to the hospital or by the
medical profession they're not studied
like men are studied most clinical
trials have not enrolled women as much
as men we haven't analyzed the data in a
sex specific way and also the biology of
women is different and we're just
starting to really say that out loud
the question should more women go to
cardiologists in addition to their GP I
think that they can it's certainly
something that and certainly if their OB
identifies things and that's one other
thing to bring up is that what happens
to you during pregnancy can be a marker
for future risks our gestational
hypertension or gestational diabetes
preeclampsia or preterm delivery early
menopause or PCOS all of these raise
your risk as does breast cancer that's
been treated with radiation or chemo
depression anxiety stress a lot of these
factors and inflammatory conditions
rheumatoid arthritis and lupus so lots
of things that raise your risk women
listening or like I've had one of those
great life saving tips Tara thank you